look
if you had i can't i can't do this do
you also think that this is one of the
most underrated characters in one piece
a character that literally gets called a
god that has awakened observation haki
and that ultimately got knocked out by
luffy
no i'm of course talking about the one
and only nl god of thunder maker of
great faces and ruler of the moon
because he plays a much more important
role in the story than you might think
nl is the only villain in the story that
is neither pirate nor marine he's just
this random guy with a ridiculously
powerful devil fruit that has an
absolutely terrible god complex
the great thing about enel is that we
can talk about both his absolutely
fantastic character as well as all the
world building that surrounds him and
the arc of skypia seriously do you even
remember how much world building we got
through nl so what exactly was annal's
role in the story what does he teach us
about the one piece world and will he
ever come back from the moon this is the
story of gods nfl
when you really think about it at the
time nl and the skypia arc felt sort of
out of place with the rest of the story
usually arcs tie into each other like
fishman island and arlon park build up
to a climax like the alabasta awana saga
or represent a fundamental turning point
in the story like marine forts every new
island that the straw hat visit and
every new villain we meet fits in
smoothly with the path that the straw
hats have taken so far and brings them
closer to their goal and then there is
this entire arc up in the clouds that
almost seems to be a sight adventure for
the crew where we get to see robin as
part of the straw hats the spirit of the
mary and the importance of dreams and
believing in them
[Music]
the villain is yet another corrupt ruler
of a country that has to be liberated by
luffy but i would argue that it's just
the opposite skypea might actually turn
out to be one of the most important arcs
in the entire story and nl one of the
most interesting
[Music]
personality characters i think you agree
that enel is an egocentric maniac skypia
which is inhabited by three races of sky
people is full of conflict when we first
get there we have the tribal shandians
who were at war with the angel-like
skypeans only for enel to come in and
make enemies out of both he conquers
their land and declares himself god
ruling from the comfort of his residence
we're surrounded by pretty women with
his heavenly mantra he controls and
observes anyone who would speak bad of
him
[Music]
and in general the god theme is actually
pretty strong with eno first of all his
name nl is most likely based on the
deity enlil or l from which many names
honoring the biblical god are
descendants michael raphael ezekiel you
get the idea funnily enough enol is also
the name of italy's largest electricity
provider
now enol's thunder powers of course are
reminiscent of deities like zeus while
the metal ring with the tomoa drum set
into his back are clearly inspired by
the japanese thunder deity raijin by the
way this must be the most uncomfortable
piercing anyone ever had
[Music]
in other words oda made it a point to
mash as many different gods into this
character as possible and the cherry on
top is the fact that anal's big goal is
leaving earth and reaching the fairy
worth or as i like to call it moon
for anil the moon is the natural realm
of god so clearly he must get there
after all he believes himself to be a
god
a god complex is an unshakable belief in
one's own importance characterized by
constantly inflated feelings of personal
ability privilege and infallibility
[Music]
and so a person with a god complex may
refuse to admit the possibility of their
error or failure even in the face of
irrefutable evidence in traceable
problems or difficult or impossible
tasks
[Music]
such a person is also highly dogmatic in
their views meaning that this person
speaks of their personal opinions as
though they were unquestionable facts
and so someone with a god complex may
exhibit no regard for the conventions
and demands of society and may request
special consideration and privileges
basically making all of this a very
severe form of narcissism
i'm sure some of you just felt like i
described someone you know
please make sure they don't get their
hands on the devil fruit now
understandably all this may sound
twisted and delusional to you
because it is but anal has the power to
back it up wielding the powerful goro
goronomi which allows him to control
transform into and create electricity at
will next to blackbeard's yami yaminomi
and whitebeard's gouda guranomi it's
named as one of the most powerful and
destructive devil fruits in the one
piece worlds
so powerful in fact that it can easily
annihilate an entire island something
that the ancient weapon pluton is
infamous for so anal is basically a
one-man buster call if you want
[Music]
oda even stated that at the time nl
would have gained a bounty of at least
500 million berries if he were a pirate
down on earth simply for his power alone
but enol was not only strong and evil
terrifying a whole island he's also
charismatically smart and has a decent
sense of humor as well
[Music]
now just to get it straight anal can
come across as pretty stupid in some
ways and in some ways he is but he's
also the same guy who restarted his own
heart and built a goddamn spaceship
powered by himself to reach the moon and
here people are saying that luffy is
creative with his devil fruit enel is
not a villain he's an experience
[Music]
what fundamentally sets anil apart from
other antagonists in the story is his
arc with luffy which is also why i
strongly believe that we will get to see
him again in the story here's the deal
for most major villains in the story
just like for eno we get a decent amount
of setup just for how bad and evil they
are and indeed we do get the impression
of how tyrannical and frightening his
rule over skypia truly is plus remember
that anal and his men are messing most
of the straw heads up worse than in
almost any other arc at that point the
fact that enel himself came for many of
the straw hats unlike even crocodile was
a first that made it clear just how much
of a threat to the crew he truly was
and yet despite all of that anal's
encounter with luffy like some of the
most fundamental elements all other
major villains in one piece share first
of all we get no backstory or motivation
for his actions all we know is that he
destroyed the island of his people berka
and took an army with him to subdue
skypia what's up with that we don't know
why he ended up destroying an entire
island why he doesn't have wings where
he got his devil fruit or why he even
wants to go to the moon so desperately i
have no idea i hope you agree that anal
is the type of character that seems to
have a very fascinating and relevant
backstory and we never get to hear it
the second thing is that luffy's actions
always punish the villain in some way or
form for their deeds and and their
desire crocodile and doflamingo end up
in prison
luchi has to let robin escape
caesar loses his lap
big mom loses the vinsmoke technology
you get the idea enel however while roth
of the golden bell simply proceeds with
his plans to go to the moon as if
nothing had happened yes luffy protects
gaipia and fulfills his promise to ring
the bell but he doesn't change nl or
stop his initial goal and so to me these
two things strongly suggest that enel
might well return at some point later in
the story
but of course there is a lot more to
that now let's get into world building
oh boy
work to start first of all as you know
enel is the first enemy that openly uses
observation hack against luffy also
pretty damn potent observation hockey at
that being aware of the entire islands
since we haven't met whitebeard yet this
is also the very first devil fruit we
meet that in terms of destructibility
blows everything completely out of
proportion smoke and crocodile look
pretty ridiculous compared to this
[Music]
the most important thing about skypia
however is what it tells us about the
history of the world skypia tells us not
only about the existence of islands in
the sky an entire world above the clouds
it teaches us a lot about the past as it
turns out shandora the ancient city of
one of the sky races was in some way or
form affiliated with the ancient kingdom
not only do we find opponent live there
pointing to fishman island a totally
different world but we also find a
legendary city of gold that already
trumps anything the one piece treasure
could offer in terms of gold and silver
additionally we're also introduced to
noland a very roger-like character that
seems to play a very important role in
the story as well
[Applause]
but as if all of this wasn't enough
already we also find out in probably the
most important and crazy cover story we
ever got that this race of sky people
did not only have an ancient
civilization down on earth all three of
the races actually come from the very
same moon that anal went
[Music]
and here things get crazy we learned
that the sky people had this
ridiculously advanced country there on
the moon creating sentient machines
before flying down to earth after using
up all the resources there we also see
some of these same robots being built on
karakuri island accidentally the same
highly technological place that dr
vegapunk is from and where frankie spent
the time skipped
oh yeah and there are space pirates as
well and their logo looks exactly like
fukurokujo from wano who has the exact
same earlobes as eno
and
you see i'm pretty sure skypia will be
one of the most important arcs in
retrospect once we enter the end game i
actually have an absolutely fantastic
theory in store for you guys about the
ancient kingdom and skypia so if you're
interested in that let me know in the
comments and going back to nl who now
has this entire army of robots on the
moon one more important thing is the
name of his home that he destroyed
burka
you see burqa is not only the name of
the ancient moon city but also a real
historical place the real-life burqa was
one of the most important trade centers
in scandinavia during the viking age and
what island is viking themed yes you
exactly albath 10 points to hufflepuff
and we know that elbaf has this giant
tree growing into the sky and we also
know that there is a proper entrance to
the sky islands somewhere in the new
world
coincidence i think not now all of this
implies to me that one of the most
interesting characters with an
unfinished character arc should come
back at some point in the future and
even if he doesn't nl wasn't just a
villain he was
an experienced
[Music]